if you really want to get the oc back up
and running of course we could like of
course there's a way
characters can like slightly change or
diverge to come back as
a cousin like who cares let's talk about
this movie it's called
brie it's out on demand in theaters
on august 14th this movie i feel like
says a lot about
the younger generation's obsession with
getting followers from getting likes and
getting views
what is your relationship like with
social media
i'm engaged in it and very interested in
it and also
like very standoffish with it so i
like learn to put it down when it just
doesn't serve me and i don't post
that much very often i've been lucky
because i think my fans like ever since
the oc
are kind of like die hard loyal like my
friends always laugh because i've got
like a really like
international sweet like fan base of
people who
are generally behave themselves on on my
social media which i think is great
what would it have been like if you guys
had social media when you were shooting
the oc i think it would have been cool
actually in a lot of ways because i
think we would have been able to give
ourselves more of a voice the press at
the time were really able to kind of run
with it like we were constantly being
paparazzi
anyway so i felt like we never really
got to direct our own
like narrative when it came to things
you know there was just a lot of
speculation
the one good thing about social media
i've noticed is now
is like you can really speak your truth
and you can come back
so it's not just all left in the hands
of people who don't know you
and don't know what's really going on on
set so i think
you know what it would have been pretty
cool i want to take you down every lane
for a minute because
it was actually in 2003 this very week
that the oc premiered no way really
yeah isn't that crazy it was a big idea
what would you tell that girl on set i
mean now you're still making movies
like you're still working if you could
tell
your younger students we were having so
much fun i mean we really were
the beginning of that show was super
easy the ends of shows are always
wearing it's complicated you know what i
mean like the beginning was fun
and free and carefree and i was like you
know
new to hollywood i mean i just didn't
know much i literally left high school
and came straight to california and was
cast in that role and i had to fight
really hard for it too
it was an interesting time and place
also in pop culture and
i don't i don't know but i it was a good
time
we do want to show you something that we
found from 2003
oh cost a lot more recognizable to
people on the street now
so it changes like the little things you
do in everyday life like going out to
dinner and having people coming up to
you and like
falling in love with your character and
being like tell me what happens with
marissa on the show and
also things are just a lot busier now i
was so used to like i think last year
wow i had so much down time you know
absolutely like stuff i was really lucky
i was being pretty lazy and this year
just things move really fast i love that
that's what i called lazy too
lazy um that's so funny first of all i'm
talking so fast
second of all yeah that's called your
20s for you that's funny because we were
talking
just the day before yesterday about
going to the airport and like how when
my character died
people would come up to me in the
airport just crying and like thinking
that it was
somehow part of real life yeah i was
just joking about that with a friend of
mine the other day
so that's really funny that makes me
smile i think ben mckenzie last week
talked about it and said hopefully the
fans felt
satisfied he was like it was a little
bit odd but i hope the fans were happy
do you ever want to rewrite marissa's
death or do you feel
like that was the way for her to go out
still i feel like i hope the fans were
satisfied too
but there was so much drama on that set
that i feel like it
kind of reached it's like and so also
with marissa herself as a character like
you know we had done a lot of story
lines with her
and we'd sort of seen every which way
and ever
for her to go and that felt like it was
doing the character justice
but i do understand like people wanting
her to like maybe come back and be
raised from the dead so that she could
be
back up to her old antics and in that
sense like i can relate to people's
like need for that yeah
that was more dramatic that said of the
oc or the set of the hills
you're putting me on the spot
okay she's gonna drink her teeth i'm
shocked to hear though that there was
drama
on the set of the oca there was some
like dating going on and like
you know everybody was young and newly
famous
and there was a lot of different story
lines to fulfill there too
and but no i mean i think bizarrely
all sets have a lot of drama especially
those big tv shows like riverdale or
like you know like
it's like there's always going to be
stuff going on like that's just the way
it is people think people
you know have have their own things and
their lives going on and you try not to
bring that baggage to set and you try to
leave it behind
but um that doesn't always work but yeah
no not dramatic in a reality tv
did you date anyone on that set no
i can't tell you anything you know how
many fans heads would just like explode
if you were like yeah
and mackenzie yeah
no are you seeing like a new influx of
fans because the oc is streaming now
it's been very active lately in terms of
the fact so i
realized it must be streaming again
because i was like where are all these
young fans coming from
would you ever think that the show could
be rebooted with a new cast i mean we
heard fresh prince is coming back
as a reboot it's so cool it makes me so
happy that those shows are coming back
because they make people so happy myself
included um
i don't know yeah i think there are ways
it could happen for sure
i mean in this industry there's a way to
do everything i mean if you really want
to get the oc
back up and running of course we could
like of course there's a way
yeah i mean characters can like slightly
change or diverge
come back as a cousin like who cares
like there's so many million different
ways to rewrite something and
and retell the same story in a slightly
different way
and i definitely don't think that that
story is dead either because
orange county like the oc is not what
the hills or laguna beach was those were
reality shows so they didn't really like
it's not the same thing they are two
totally different things like there's
definitely room for like an
ocs drama